the new US Congress is 80% white 80%
male and 92% Christian and as I said
believe it or not it's still considered
the most diverse Congress in US history
now we actually have one member of this
diverse new Congress with us tonight
please welcome from North Dakota
Wesley Davenport areas now I know he may
look like just another white male
Christian but here are some facts about
this new member of Congress that may
surprise you for example he uses salsa
on his eggs yeah he can tell Kevin Hart
and Chris Rock apart
he buys his Wall Street Journal from a
Filipino vendor he thinks Neil Patrick
Harris does a fine job playing straight
guys his mistress is one-quarter Asian
he's an Episcopalian on the streets and
a presbyterian in the sheets
he once watched blackish
accidentally he meant to DVR the
blacklist he led his stepdaughter go to
an Aziz Ansari show and he has nothing
but good things to say about his quote
Jew lawyer anything else anything else
you'd like to share with us congressman
I just tried Greek yogurt and it didn't
seem that gay
[Applause]
you